bientôt c'est sous les yeux de dieu se
retrouve une nouvelle fois sur spock et
house of james car souvenez vous c'est
le lieu dans lequel dans lequel il ya
environ 1000 salles actuellement il ya
une nouvelle mise à jour ce soir dérape
on n'avait pas fini de toute manière on
va reprendre là on s'était arrêté
on s'était donc arrêté chambre 300 dans
un checkpoint souvenez vous il ya des
checkpoints ou les 50 chambres on appuie
sur le gros bouton là juste là ah non
pas le bouton d'acné qui était tout de
suite cette vidéo c'est pas drôle et la
pratique latine je sais qu'il est
flippant alors que tout est mignon
dedans famille long des voies dénonce un
peu bizarre quand même mais je veux
qu'on a aujourd'hui à la chambre
huit cent mille huit cent mille noms
j'ai le coeur sous les cèdres à pizza
est une donnée notamment à lui pardonner
alors c'est vraiment gentil jean brault
310 l'humidité ce féraud c'est quoi ça a
indiqué alan kay absolument pas de porte
quoi faut que jamais en a assez étaient
cachés ils sont doués en 2000 à sa part
en sectes quoi c'est quoi ça c'est une
clé et ça je peux pas prendre décision
pour dénoncer l'immense notamment par
une feuille a4 totalement inoffensive ça
je peux y aller un voile à la porte de
la mort en plein on a la clé chambre
c'est un monstre savons tous où ces
usages coiffeur plutôt aimable au du
cache pas ce qui peut coiffer et là sur
le caillou allait quitter cette vidéo
maintenant si j'ai plus de 20 km est un
petit boîtier tout sur une page de
quel est le québec fut qu'un doigt
dessus d'un oeil aux nouvelles rapproche
le co2 l'inde pour les morts ces
variations 310 à ce à partir en couille
a des yeux des illuminati et où c'est
d'ailleurs un coiffeur illuminati gelé
vue coiffe la pyramide et tout est
toujours belle gosse est permis sur les
photos on sait pourquoi alors nous
revoilà donc si je me souviens bien fois
les là pas du tout nickel faut se marier
à gauche me ferais pas voir cette fois
aux mets mais qui met un couac au plus
tard alors espèces de petites ampoules
et de coiffure illuminati on va voir si
tu fais le malin attente est que
ah c'est ça faut le regarder le tuc nul
oo le maquis l'ultra violent quoi je
couperai sa tête et ma métro au bout
d'un pic le pic sera un cure dent avec
le cas je mange rien délicieux corniche
ou à danser alors jégo estime ps où la
petite fille qui nous parlait pas du
tout j'étais rassuré une demi-seconde ça
fait plaisir et c'est le tchèque bonne
[ __ ] non aux nantais ça mais c'est non
si tous les 50 cc tous les sens pour
celui là bon bah se trouve dans 22
minutes et il nous reste 35 xiam
affaires sont décédées et c'est là le
butin était dégueulasse et le plus
mignon lapland millions dans le jeu
c'est dégueulasse que ma coupe de
cheveux dans les belles et très bien aux
[ __ ] au km h est moche c'est bon on
est arrivé on arrivait le tchèque s'est
regardé les enfants il ya 800 chambres
on n'est qu'à la moitié
oh je sais que je crois je suis
empoisonnée c'est quoi ça alors juste
tout va mal quoi on à ckoi samui a
laissé fuir je suis pacifiste dans la
vie je mange que des végétaux et j'aime
beaucoup écouter du lori un surtout
améliorable est vraiment bien comme
chanson ya une sorte de pâte on
regardait ses deux pattes de poulets
fusionnée qui me qui mieux chasse en
modeuse alléchante 426 et bordel voilà
on comprend plus rien non il ya mon ski
me suis tu as si je vais maintenant je
vais avoir les boules à ger avoir les
boules les glandes les cordonniers qui
pendent voilà comme garde enfants de ce1
on à la chambre 14 55 ans voire 45 avant
le checkpoint et y'a rien à signaler
oh non [ __ ] non non non je me souviens
de ça ça sent la merde façon
généralement quand tu tombes sur un beau
qu'avec de la flotte et un cerveau qui
flotte de danse et on finit jamais bien
au [ __ ] c'est quoi ça intérieur est
nul c'est l'espoir qui courtisent berns
à ce que moi j'ai vécu la pression plus
que 35 aux mondiaux le corps le coeur
lourd pour entraîner pour le marathon je
fais ça en fait ça fait tellement bougé
mon coeur qu'après je suis prêt je suis
prêt il carbure il envoie de l'air comme
il faut dans les poumons et dans les
muscles va pas de même dans les muscles
du san vito parce que de les envoyer
mais s'avère un peu chaude ou au plus
tard ya un monde qui me suit les gars
assez le monde de la brume je déteste ça
part en couille total plus que delachaux
non non oui au lac et al oui je suis là
en vie est toujours là oui c'est moi on
est les participantes ont été réparés
pour toi donc qui fait profite
oui je vais je vais profiter houvion est
bon on y va aller direction la chambre
800 je m'appelle jean françois attends
attends qu il lui faut que j'ai
recommencé la chambre 55 là non c'est
faux bon remake soit possible mais bien
celle où tu rentres first à il ya un
truc que je vais ramasser une note
error nickel mais c'est pour les autres
vraiment à la roue de 61 [ __ ] express
une elle attend ça me fait ça peut-être
le faire remonter la chambre 562 512
pardon fallait pas paniquer pour elle
faisait paniquer ou jetteront pas
paniquer quoi allez on se retrouve des
kermesses kinshasa
oh mon dieu je crois qu avance tout de
suite à [ __ ] de rêve des faux je
regarde c'est le monde de la porte c'est
le démon illuminatis ah ah je suspends
sueur [ __ ] mais sur un shoot evidian
quoi elle est battue à son pavilion
aussi un croyez moi la musique c'est pas
dit oui c'est plus dû à ses maris partis
n'osent pas se monter à c'est vraiment
des couilles molles et devrait vraiment
très très laid breakfast nouveau look
pour une nouvelle vie à ces monstres
nouveau mons pour une nouvelle terreur
voilà c'est ma blague à petit et la
vidéo je voulais dit plein de fois à la
fois le mec il assez de talent en place
un blog qui demande aux gens de quitter
la vidéo tellement il ajoute qu à 7,3 et
l'ong ya plus de mons nous sommes en
totale sérénité actuellement même les
doigts de pieds veulent vous faire ifile
voilà au ca 150 qu'est ce que c'est que
ce bordel
ok je passe voir un petit jardin
tranquillement d'une véranda alors est
ok aussi génial au changement de décor
dans le bar à damas comme des maître
gims tapie n'a à toto school adjointe au
vif the role in china china chemin ko
après avoir eu un serment qui vendent
ensuite dans un jeu d'horreur on a des
[ __ ] de biche type lame à vire au
monde délicatement donc j'attends agepa
prend le risque de mourir un anneau -
karine cause cependant si tu parles
c'est là à droite
regardez et une bille sur le chemin je
vais attendre va attendre ta ça se
transforme en survival horror quoi
survivent est allé d'une tâche qu'on
trouve des [ __ ] de biche de bh contre
haut débit tchatche à nouveau mons non
non on l'appelle l'ancienne télévision
elle tente aimé du grain ton image en
noir et blanc elle mais même des
musiques de l'époque elle est ultra
terrifiante l a tuée ta mère ton père
t'a biche jawbone obama est en train de
bouffer c'est moi les parties [ __ ] on
va se regardent avant de s'enflammer à
des soins
un peu
ah j'aime bien ce décor il est beaucoup
moins glauque que ceux d'avant ça me
fait très plaisir voilà homo je dis ça
ça devient violet un peu des monts
s'écoule à ckoi ok ok on est une lampe
torche et tout mais j'adore que ça
change le décor comme ça mais pas trop
non plus fin voilà j'ai rallumé la
centrale est donc l'époque qui vont avec
faut rétablir le courant passait par là
a sonné dans les conduites par sur un
look classe comme ça calmement honiara
ya un rat est à mon avis le rail veut
pas lui mais il va pas nous rater un oh
merde en mer mais la parole est vraiment
s'ils n'ont pas gagné 1 soit on sait
jamais il peut nous rattraper en
l'espace d'une fraction de seconde plus
vite que florent manaudou à la piscine
ludique alexandra ledermann sur un
cheval plus vite que ce quiz et pour
acculer encore la blague perverse nul
hôpital et là haut mais qui l'habite
mâchoire et non ils avaient plus grosse
fracture ok mon gars ok les enfants dès
la moitié du parcours pour atteindre le
checkpoint en août un homo je vais
parler il a prédit il a prédit ça vous
laisser vous dire tais toi en langage
des des monstres mignon en carton qui
sortent des murs et cette phrase est
longue en mode you yeah man ce qui me
suis alors j'ai 15 ans a passé sans
mourir c'est pas grave c'est pas vrai ça
passe à passer au bloc de la part de
champreux maicon à michael attention la
dernière les enfants manger qu'un seul
truc à vous dire autant
petit touche au mot 710 sa part en
onomatopées actuellement on est ou kfc
ou voulait la la c'est ouvert n'ont rien
ouvert si génial mais peut-être aller à
droite à aa aly kane et bien nous en
resterons quoi c'est par complètement
aux couilles attend à tout moment au
risque de se voir attaquer par du bacon
jeu en plus quoi atouts et des femmes
auxquels j'ai pris une clé du prix qu'il
y avait une clé cachée aux toilettes la
ecuador un truc h et aussi je comprends
plus rien les enfants sa part totalement
en couilles mais bh outlook grande force
pourquoi y'a quoi une clause de couper
le poulet ou pas encore une clé [ __ ]
excideuil
c'est bon ce barreau soit au plus tard
il ya un monstre et ramos et nous aura
pas parce que powell kannad petit groupe
à j'ai le coeur qui bat vite je vous
jure je crois c'est vrai ça être
cardiaque cette [ __ ] d'histoire la
seoul à elle la porte était la fête pas
joe calderone team dessus la barre était
de faire disparaître des portes voilà ce
qui est totalement fils de [ __ ] rit on
dit dans le milieu que c'est bon elle a
disparu on revoit les ports c'est
fantastique
elle dit magyd tu vois pas les portes
pour aller travailler tu voulais partir
soirs de matchs joués c'est de la merde
voilà squeeze sur scène à partir du 6
novembre dans la cantine du collège jean
françois millet ont quitté la vidéo puis
un peu plus a ajouté ross sur les bears
je vais aviser à la 750 aux assiettes
poète mon gars je pensais pas que tu le
ferais que tirer aussi loin et tu as une
hache
c'est bien félicitations j'ai pas de
cadeau pour toi donc chat elle m'a donné
du de la stamina nuitées d'énergie
limitée je peux courir de manière
totalement limité à non [ __ ] la moitié
j'ai plus d'énergie mon gars en fait je
peux plus courir
le jeu n'est pas complétée après cet
endroit mais ses entrées pour continuer
ou backspace pour mourir à temps j'ai
oublié la démo thème du paquebot
marquoir moment c'est le jeu qui te
respect que le moins du monde sans
déconner il fait peur avec des morceaux
de cartons qui sort du mur tu te
poursuivre par le coiffeur des
illuminati il s'amuse à faire
disparaître les ports devant toi comme
ça et en plus il veut en plus on l'a
fait j'ai hâte
et connaissances du diaphragme cette
vidéo sur ce pokémon john church pensais
pas qu'on allait le faire je suis hyper
heureux merci d'avoir accompagné
merci d'avoir soutenu dans cette
terrible aventure oui je fais un
discours en pleine vidéo je m'en fous
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo si vous
appelez ça fera plaisir aujourd'hui
j'avais envie de nous fixer un petit
challenge voilà de finir cette [ __ ] de
demos était blond est rude
bon sinon tu avais dans une prochaine
vidéo merci d'avoir regardé n'oubliez
pas tout ce qui est mignon peut faire
peur c'est cette morale picciotto pis
[Musique]